welcome back to drew's news rusty what's
next well we got another dream job
listing listen to this mental floss
reports a company called petable will
pay you a thousand dollars to watch a
bunch of dog movies uh anyone in
yeah
hello
right and here's how it breaks down you
get a hundred dollars an hour to watch
six movies and they are marley and me a
dog's i know a dog's journey
because of winn-dixie eight below lady
and the [ __ ]
and the call of the wild and they'll
cover all the rental costs but you're
responsible for your own tissues because
some of those movies are rough
but
stupid but i will say they missed uh
what can i just throw out beverly hills
chihuahua please i love that movie so
much and i know i know so steaming mad
they didn't call me for the sequel
i tried i worked really hard on chloe
beverly hills chihuahua talk about an
oscar movie that should have been i'm
calling ambody for that
i loved it and in all the things you've
done in your career being a voice in
beverly hills chihuahua is one of my i'm
most jealous of that i think
well because you have chihuahuas that's
why yes and i have studied them drew i
know how to be a chihuahua well then you
know what rex reed i'd love to know how
you thought i did actually i thought
earnestness maybe there's a reason i
didn't get called back from the second
movie listen i thought you were great
and i'm not just throwing you a bone
what would your favorite dog movie be
rozzy of all time
besides that probably lady and the [ __ ]
i think that's why i love spaghetti so
much it's because of that movie yeah and
wellie nose to nose on the pasta strands
oh man so ours would be like a zucchini
noodle because i'm trying to keep it
together for the way it would totally be
a zoodle
zoodle i would have to pick marley and
me that movie is one of my favorite
movies ever made
so sweet you know you throw a dog in
anything and people are gonna like it
yeah
i mean i bark
i do i feel
commit i get
i go all the way
and they didn't call me back for the
sequel
this is an injustice
who's over at this studio right now is
like that little
um okay and our last story moving on
apparently i haven't moved no
there's a dilemma that recently came
into the advice column at usa today
someone wrote in to say three of their
friends in their group are notoriously
tardy or late for every hangout party
and occasion so for a recent night out
the punctual friends told the late
friends that the event started at 9 pm
where the real start time was 10. this
time the friends actually weirdly made
it a concerted effort to show up early
they got there at 8 30 waited an hour
and a half and were cranky and furious
about it the rest of the night and now
these friends are no longer talking
and the letter writer wants to know who
was in the wrong
who here is notoriously late
raise your hands do it
recognize it in yourself it's a flaw and
a selfish one and horrible i see you
leaning into your friend and whispering
in her raise it don't just admit it
right now that you're a you're a bad
naughty person
we are in the wrong the late people are
in the wrong that's all i have to say so
you are one of those people who
yes i try not to be i try not to be i i
i i i
i i'm working on it yeah i'm getting
better i've improved immensely
um i really have there is room for hope
uh and i can tell you that it is
terrible time management i put on an
instagram thing that's like um michael
uh from the office and it says i'm
running at 9 10 hoping to make it to the
office by 9 a.m uh-huh and
and so i'm working on it and people who
are late are in the wrong but i am
working on it and i'm sickened yeah with
myself
you know
you know there's um
there's a quote i like from the famous
poet kim zolciak who said don't be tardy
for the party okay
remind yourself of that
next time
i know it's gotten better we there's i'm
telling you all of us who raised our
hands
we can fix this
i believe that you can i have improved
no that was my audition for the next um
beverly hills
how would i did you was it believable
put some panting in a rough in there
say we're going to break in a dog voice
we'll be right back
[Music]
you